hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to off we are about to
oh that's a booger that was a symbol on
the door but we are about to face off
with the final boss Valerie Valerie that
that is the name of the cat you are
mistaking me for someone else
I am Jeff it the Firebird not in a zone
to stop with these paranoid delusions
dear brother come with me to zone 0 I
have built a cellar where we can forget
our sorrows I am NOT your brother I do
not even belong to any race of bread
eaters take a look at my real face you
poor smelly cat Oh Valerie you do not
understand do you
I am NOT Valerie I am Japheth I have
taken control of your miserable little
brother unable to even chew through a
little bird until the end
hmm whatever Javed I'm here to destroy
you you who claim to control the
spectres I was waiting better I will not
go down without a fight
hmm Valerie that's good for you I got a
fight just in store you must understand
those fools they only care about their
own pathetic hassles I need everything
for them they are like my own countless
children and like all this respect for
sure
they need to be punished well you also
need to be punished now I'm gonna make
sure that you get the proper deliverance
on to your backside funk funk how we and
then [ __ ] ok this battle is obviously
gonna take a while because it's a boss
battle but I'm not gonna skip it because
I know that you guys want to see these
in what oh oh I muted ok sorry I don't
know everything that's going on these
systems the battle system is pretty
similar though I am NOT a god I cannot
be perfect yes I have sinned
I admit it but my responsibilities are
far beyond those of a mere mortal I'll
take a fury some right it doesn't matter
you're gonna be purified nonetheless and
still muted then there we go unmuted
yeah somebody's hard because oh hello uh
mr. Chi you seem down something coming
out of your face you know you're not
worried about that at all alright if
you're not worried I guess I'm the
rhythm goddamn stop muting my dudes I
need to have them unmuted so that I can
beat your face in more properly because
you seem to have something coming out of
your face
alright purifier you're going to seal my
fate no matter I am ready to die at
first prepare yourself to see my true
okay Frieza thank you very much oh how
did you fit in that cat that's something
you shouldn't bring up a normal
conversation
I am Javed Lord in the second zone
I'm the Millennial Firebird let the
battle begin
and with this cat hat on my head I shall
not have any problem dealing with you
this guy really is freezing over here
monologuing his ass off oh by the way I
just started watching DBZ a bridge
recently and I know I'm Way late to the
game on that one but oh my god that hit
really hard that's what she said but
wowie Zowie
okay so save second base I learned is a
more powerful heal so that I can get my
guys up ready going holy crap 3:12
what the hell ha joke's on you Orville
can't be feared by nobody who's that
Oliver no that's Orville oh whoops
I guess I was kind of needed but I don't
worry this is the only guy that I worry
about hitting them jeez it sets a lot of
licking damage okay come here I'm gonna
heal you and we're all back up to normal
and everyone's gonna be just fine and
you're gonna be just dead very soon
well then okay cut ah tell why did you
decide to be inside of a cat there's a
lot of more pleasant places that you
could have been for a bird I mean maybe
you had a suicide wish it first but wow
geez man those poisons would really kill
me oh I have a cure poison thing okay
those poison cure this guy's smacking
really hard I also have items that I can
use to do all that sort of stuff but
sometimes I forget about that geez
when did I start doing so much damage I
know I upgra - oh that's not good ah no
I need you to hit him I'm gonna you use
an item you're gonna die aren't you
fortune take it on you hey didn't I not
that death would have been that big of a
deal because I have abilities that can
bring people back to life okay you're
gonna use another fortune ticket on your
buddy over there actually would probably
be better not to waste a fortune tickets
and just use a whole the guy's ability
to heal the friends and then just bring
up his CPU later but that's more
strategizing theorycrafting than you
guys need all I need to know is that I'm
wasting stuff by accidentally pressing
the wrong buttons at the wrong time ah
there we go
silver flush back me up and then I'm
gonna heal him next turn unless he dies
don't die please God this guy hits
really hard nah stop doing that stop
being such an a-hole
ah you need a silver flesh oh I'm so
dumb I'm so bad
don't kill yes thank you very much uh he
was about to kill him okay not do that
again
oh and Cara's poison if I'm gonna keep
doing the stupid attack I might as well
do it in the right place such an idiot
oh just gala bomb I don't know how much
health he has that's not something that
I can analyze in this particular battle
oh by the way some people said that they
wanted me to analyze more of the regular
enemies because I need to take a closer
look at him because things are not what
they seem in this game and I'm already
starting to realize that always dead
good good thing I have a joker oh did
you come back oh he does not come back
with full health
once the almost what's the point of
doing it all right this guy better be
getting to dead soon hey boys stop that
don't hit him so hard I need you to heal
yourself with a lock ticket that's all
you get all God didn't do enough all
right whatever you know you're just
gonna do right Oh suck on that
chop it I have a serious birth that's a
lot of exp that's a lot of credits
I got a pisces card but a level nine
very nice
oh that's so sad so I have been slain
you can be proud to have accomplished
your mission batter
oh he tweets like a little bird Valerie
you've been defeated ja fit guardian of
the second zone this land is now pure
why am i killing the Guardians this
doesn't seem like a good thing although
they are kind of infecting the entire
land with spirits what I like to save
absolutely.i word I'm spreading the
saves out a lot just in case of bugs out
again hello little baby creature I don't
know you but this yet are you the queen
Oh lovely you don't look very queen
shepherd he left - oh that's a citizen
voice um who are you oh I'm back in the
nothingness now okay now one commoner
said or a lot of comander said but one
person in particular was really adamant
that I go back to other zones that I've
beaten before moving on because it's
very important so I'm gonna go back to
zone zero see what's going on and then
move on to zone three
am i loving furs anything in particular
am i looking for anything out of the
ordinary
cuz this looks weightless this looks
pretty much exactly the same this is a
tutorial island God seems like forever
since I've been back here hello are you
doing here
yeah have you - I don't know your voice
seemed Pablo around here who's Pablo
what wait do you have anything special
oh this is all downgrades well what the
body you be here what's the point of me
being here okay well then that was
interesting was there a Padano here that
I was supposed to go to look can I move
around the nothingness no limited okay
Zone one maybe yes enter Zone one oh
this is like the ocean good wide ocean
another net
oh it's lucky oh oh what's going on here
there's no tram anymore it's just over
here about an inspiration yay maybe I
can paint this whole town red because it
seemed to be lacking some color it
wasn't black and white last time I went
here was it something happen waving that
whispering now whispering is in the
nothingness was that in the lake too
oh hey well I can't go back down there
oh well is this why I needed to go back
and dd-do didn't might seem it does be
that thing that you are telling me to do
and indeed it is okay so now we're
getting somewhere I got a fortune ticket
- let's see what we says hey I remember
that wasn't that on the ocean - wait is
there someone actually here that needs
help what are you are you oh oh please
go away
I don't see your face anymore oh you're
tough aren't you okay there you go
natural whoa
Oh what l haven't here I thought I'd
survive this blaze oh go away die I
please oh come on why are the normal
attacks so wimpy stop screaming at my
guys people are just trying to finger my
circles and then scream at my circles I
don't want to do that anymore stop
fingering and screaming at my holes
Jesus second I had a lot of health then
again I wasn't doing my combat attacks
that is a lot of experience was I
supposed to come back here now like I
was tough ease what the hell happened
here
I thought I purified this area I did
didn't I
this doesn't seem pure are you pure are
you the pure people where your heads so
big what is wrong with you where are you
go guru God how much else do you have
just fall over and die oh my god ah
creepiest trigger brac seriously what
the what the hell happened though why is
this like this i purified this zone what
happened after Lord prefer the ghost to
us at least people were living in this
area now there's no one here unless
these are the people here why is it
whispering what am i doing what is the
batter doing we know the batter is still
fighting him why am I here
this doesn't make any sense this doesn't
make any sense when in a circle did this
doesn't make any sense at all just the
one eeeh well I've got a special
surprise for you it's okay Jesus I
didn't get two steps what is with you
hang on
secretary diabolical humanoid spirit
light weakness against plastic lay
resistance again what does that even
mean what does that mean what are you
diabolical humanoid uh you're just a
gross going out Oh with a weird head and
weird
what aren't you even half feet what is
with you you're weird
wait a minute what is that whispering
saying to me oh no oh you're so weird
Oh seriously what is that what's Pring
saying to me because I think I can
determine German words and from what I
heard I think it was like he it's your
fault
are you Oh who's doing that help how can
I help I can't even help myself I
couldn't even help this zone apparently
something went horror
hello rocks what are you doing here oh I
can't go that way
okay it's a way to get through there is
a way to get through here okay
do I want to go back to the nothingness
I kind of do but then again I kind of
don't know what's going on I guess I
didn't need to use my item okay okay oh
I can't get back over there ah crap oh
well I missed out on that so I'm not
going back whatever no one else
happening right now things are getting a
little weird
things are getting a lot weird all three
of you now well good thing I know
exactly how to beat you severe blow and
blood cramming to the face was those
words was that words that I said there I
don't know he's just all over here just
fall down
please screaming stop screaming for help
I can't help you it was good that I
killed them is that what he said I think
I think it said I think that whispering
said it was good that I killed them I'm
trying to listen to what the what the
actual whispers are telling me this is
weird guys I'm trying to piece together
what the hell is going on here
seriously what happened to this zone
this purification means that all the
normal citizens just go away and they're
replaced by diabolical entities doesn't
seem to work oh you're
I'd do it for me
Oh God for me absolutely perturbed oh
there's the tram why is it over here I
don't know it's on here that's not
interesting why not
it's nothing you're interesting to you
Oh ten eyes have been round same oh it's
good that I killed the potato Hank got a
word the Potala go where's the Potala
where's Raphael oh please tell me the
Potala is normal I'll go the four
dollars here career bordello we're gonna
go exploring because holy crap the place
is really weird
oh god what sort of water monsters am I
gonna find good do they kill them it's
good that I killed them it's good that I
killed them it's apparently really good
that I killed them don't ask me why I
don't particularly know hello shut up
hello sir 10 of Spades monday the grand
finale but that was the grand finale is
it there it is a bizarre object
associated with plastic those guys are
apparently a little bit weak to plastic
is that important oh oh there's a little
thing hello four pieces of abalones mate
wait I can't go that way why can't I go
that way
oh okay hello I don't get special water
masters I just get you to friendly
fellows good
I would whoa wait a minute run with
grace
ah you winked plastic through some
reason hey monk dead denies these these
guys are leveling me up a bit they give
a lot of experience well I guess that's
good
I guess it's good I came back here to
the land of nightmares nothingness but
my favorite place could be right next to
Disney World brother go back to the
theme Oh No the same thing probably
having his own to Disney World I blew up
Disney World
what am i do I'm literally trying to
piece together what the hell my purpose
as the batter really is because why is
this preferable I mean nothing was
really good before but at least people
are still alive uh what's in here oh
wait hang on I get and get the pattern
written down or wait a minute hang on
wait a minute oh wait a minute
is there a secret in there is there some
special way I'm supposed to go I don't
remember it I don't know I ever written
down but I think I remember who's whose
two left's left left up right left left
up right left up up wasn't that it
oh boy okay I don't think that's
actually getting me anywhere so am i
done did I do good
did I do good
I don't know if I did good guys I don't
feel like I did good
why do you keep telling me it was good
that I killed them it doesn't seem like
as good saves actually in reality very
bad oh great
only gonna get nothing is now thank you
oh the hell happened is ooh - do I want
to know that where I want to go next
okay the letters O - oh good it's
exactly the same Oh No the sign is
unreadable why did I that's not good
okay are you secretary secretary of kiss
house and health a friggin piece oh my
god I made a mistake coming here these
guys are really tough oh how am I gonna
be these guys with braised boys run with
grace and die forever why did I have to
run into three mm I don't think it's
rare Oh
God stop hitting me so hard oh please I
don't want that I don't want that I
don't like that I don't like that thank
you going
oh good lord that hurts and it heals
them I saw that heal them why did it
heal them don't do that sobbing okay
last one yay I guess oh that's not good
you lip wouldn't kill yourself okay
we're good we're doing good real good
these guys are just your friendly
neighborhood weirdo
rady he should effective morphogenetic
weirdos they have an eye to the wrong
thing again please go away please be
dead are you dead yet are you dead yet
I'm so out of here if you're not dead
there we go good lordy 4,500 experience
points it's almost as much as jaws it
gave me I'm not supposed to be here I'm
not supposed to be here yet
I'm definitely not supposed to be here I
need to eat a batons mate okay blue blue
blue everyone's all better everyone's
all better now I can forget this
horrible nightmare ever happened
I'm gonna go to dandy wall didn't you
did you know they blew up didn't you
world you damn dirty demons seriously
thought what the hell am I doing with
this place what the hell is the batter
doing here it's weirding me the frickin
frack out what the hell is any of this
happening
oh god this leads to nowhere oh god I
get to go in the mall the sign is
unreadable what is readable here Oh even
the shopkeeper in here no more that good
is also good right now I'm so happy that
this is all happening nothing on the
panel nothing on the panel god that's
absolute oh this is good too line is
nothing this place might as well be a
part of the nothingness which I think it
kind of is how do I get to you won't get
you come and get you monkeytoes ah crap
oh god just the two of you weirdos wait
a minute I think I think I think I
mistook those attacks aren't exactly the
same one of it one of the versions like
steals life and also like poisons
and then the other just does a lot of
damage that one does a lot of damage
oh you weirdos alright two more down and
I am almost dead because of that police
say level up good job Orville and Oliver
I'm so proud of you I better heal up
before anything bad happens to me
peaceable Isles meet an aura of
greatness Oh are these more of greetings
grand finale rudenko or of greatness
oh it's defensive equipment okay that's
uh I thought that had something to do
with like the grand finale but
apparently I didn't even need to come by
this way I'm gonna die
Oh someone who I worried there for a
second but look at you with your cute
face and your weird elbows and arms and
your no legs are you Hank Hills dad Oh
let me beat your face in a little more
just to determine whether you're
friendly or not no thank you goodbye
thank you oh I said mere I need to go Oh
is he dying he's dead where's that
doorway here it is Oh God what was the
point of this whoa the color of sadness
god I can't read the cat advertising
anymore I can't even go that way no more
oh I can't do nothing no more but I
gotta go through I gotta heal though and
I gotta use these save boxes to heal a
little more because I'm not doing very
well
Oh gonna do it oh I just got to find the
right I don't even remember which way
the right way to go was oh boy I think
it was down first left more left up
laughter up
oh what a piece of molix me but why is
this would open I didn't open it who
opened it if there's something in here
that I need to find I don't know what it
is but I need to find it that's good I
like being lost with a world of weirdos
Oh dad I did it Dan Oh
our guards took the loop in the beaten
looper louver if I don't go the right
way I'm never gonna get it out of here
go this way new go this way go this way
go up no man ain't right I went that way
there we go I'm getting you good now
seriously though at least I am leveling
up a crazy amount because of all this
battle experience but I don't think this
is the kind of battle experience I want
I could go my whole life without ever
encountering these weirdos ever again oh
please jumpy that's the way I'm supposed
to go I don't think it is oh good it is
ray where is this 18:05 wait a minute is
this one of the doors in the town of
village village oh oh it is oh it is I'm
in the village i purified
I'm really sorry everybody I think cuz
I'm pretty sure I've done bad let's
explore it at least 17 Oh No I might run
to write these down oh ok 1709 1805 I'm
pretty sure those were the numbers
anyway
this is 1405 wasn't it 1405
no what about what if the new chains
okay I don't remember what that one was
it was some I don't know remember where
does this go no we're good I would
rather not go anywhere two pieces of
blouse meet my favorite kind of meat axe
I prefer Avedon's to be perfectly honest
ma'am oh it's a dude what are you doing
in here dude the ghosts are gone the
color is gone everything's gone I'm now
forever safe welcome Oh Randall under
bad I did bad everybody I did I did so
bad I did bad was it bad it was no good
that I killed them I did so bad I did
bad oh I did bad okay hi yay man those
three packs are bass hard as any boss
I've fought so far in fact most of these
guys are harder than anything I've
fought so far Oh fine I am hmm
okay so I got to find the other codes
and open up the other doors I know that
I found like the grand thing but I to be
honest I don't know maybe I didn't write
that down right the door opens with a
code tonight just to open it
yeah 1805 those I remember those one of
the the down one was a certain code I
just got to remember what it was I think
it was 14 some but hey I got to remember
it hang on everybody I had it written
down somewhere oh my god 1402 I did it
but there's nothing in here so there was
no point rulers
okay I'm not here I'm not here I'm not
here I'm out here guys I found what I
needed to find I think and I am so gone
oh boy
okay so office getting extremely weird
and I'm starting to question what I'm
doing here although I was beginning to
question that a while ago and I started
teaching I'm here for bad reason but
either way I hope you're still enjoying
the series if I missed anything
important in those other worlds please
let me know in the comments below and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye ah crap